eeuu ya supera los 250 mil contagios
diarios una cifra récord a sin embargo
este viernes la fed aprobó la segunda
vacuna contra el cob y fabricada por
modernas 59 millones de dosis se van a
distribuir a partir de este domingo en
todo el país y las primeras personas en
recibir estas vacunas lo harán el lunes
a diferencia de la vacuna de facer esta
de moderna no necesita almacenamiento en
temperaturas extremadamente frías hecho
que permitirá que los estados puedan
enviar las áreas menos habitadas y
hospitales rurales la vacuna de modernas
como la de facer sin embargo se aplica
en dos dosis con un periodo de espera de
un mes entre ellas los trabajadores de
la salud y los adultos mayores más
afectados van a ser los primeros en
recibirla para generar confianza en esta
vacuna y en la de facer el
vicepresidente mike pence y su esposa se
la pusieron en un evento televisado
desde la casa blanca el líder
republicano del senado mitch mcconnell y
otros altos oficiales también se la
pusieron ya son más de 3
doce mil muertos causados por el comida
en eeuu hecho que ha generado que la
ciudad de washington prohíba comer en
restaurantes y cierre sus librerías
nuevamente para contrarrestar la alta
tasa de contagios